Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
March 18 2000.
I take what's going on out.
Ah,
what's up with you?
What do you say?
Um,
I am uh,
you know,
I realized this morning when I was washing the dishes,
I just come from the gym by Dubai and then I did my upper body.
I actually ran into somebody this past weekend.
They'll say,
dude,
I always see at the gym was,
he's like,
you're always doing legs.
That made me feel good.
You know,
being a child of the 80s,
you never did your legs.
It was just all about the upper body,
right?
Just building yourself up from the waist up,
like a house of fucking cards.
And all it took was one leg sweep,
one for Dota and putting up fucking three 15,
four times.
Still one leg sleep when dash land on your side.
Separate your shoulder.
Right?
Just covering up the skinny little legs,
trying to fucking kick the guy off you in some fucking parking lot that they put
a tent over so they could sell some bud lights with Lyman.
It.
Remember those days,
your member member that right.
We get fucking hammered and then the fucking,
the red line would shut down and we'd have to fucking steal a cat.
Sorry.
Um,
um,
I'm pitching the,
uh,
the sequel to goodwill hunting.
How soon before they reboot that,
right.
I would say goodwill,
this is a leather chair.
I'm not farting profusely here.
Um,
what was I gonna say?
Yeah,
the sequel to fucking goodwill hunting.
All right,
well marry the chick there.
Minnie driver,
he marries or they have four kids now that divorced because,
you know,
just hug and Robin Williams doesn't erase a childhood.
So eventually his demons,
because he is who we use,
came out the fucking marriage and now they get forward kids.
And uh,
the one that's most like will doesn't get along with them,
you know,
cause they're so alike.
Right.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I dunno where to,
if somehow these iron man,
they're still to actually promote the movie or fucking one of those fucking God
damn.
When is that chicken?
And there's,
there's like no end in sight to those fucking movies,
right?
It's like become an incestuous now.
Now they like doing like the oceans 11 of like superhero movies.
He's fucking poor actors,
man.
You know,
back in the day,
used to dream of getting a role of playing this,
to play to that.
Now everybody that just,
everybody's selling the a two.
And I just,
if I could just be,
if I could just be a lightening man,
I could get a bungalow in Oxnard.
Um,
but who knows.
Congratulations to Liverpool.
They one,
I missed the game yesterday.
They won two to one.
I was hoping they one to nothing.
So I could say to nil sound like I know what I'm talking about.
As far as I know,
there's still one point behind the fucking man city cuts all that Middle Eastern
money.
You want your money clean from a pure nation appear part of the world like the
United States of America.
That's right.
Cause we're always on the right side of the ball.
If there's any comedian out there listening right now,
if you want to get laughs when you go overseas,
just start reciting our propaganda.
You don't even need a set up or anything.
And people just start laughing.
Begins Afraid of people just,
they just laugh.
All right,
this standards,
what do we got here?
Oh fuck.
They're at first place by two points.
Oh my God.
God,
you gotta be shitting.
No wait,
wait,
wait.
Before I get excited.
Is it though?
Is this the latest one?
It is.
Are you fucking kidding me?
What happened?
What happened to Man City with that?
Never end in oil money.
What happened are the old breakfast buffet.
Gotcha.
The yanks came in,
but their big valleys in that big bag of cash.
Woo.
All right.
I love it.
I love money against money cause I'm a capitalist.
I want to see how this is going down.
Is there anything better than watching these giant hardware stores?
Just putting each other on a business.
I can't get enough of it.
Just fucking throw it down like bloodsport on to view and to be the ones that
shallow the how much no one was shut.
I have and this part of the region is part of the world unless we show,
oh,
oh.
What's that?
You want to build something?
It was called [inaudible].
We rolling off the allies.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
uploading ahead here.
Uh,
this morning after I went to the gym,
did my legs yesterday,
my pasty spindly legs that just never seem to want to get any bigger,
but I have to do them to,
to,
to keep my a cyanic nerve issue at bay because what happened after years and
years that drive in myself stuck gigs,
right?
Play in every shit hole from here to fucking uh,
Chilkoot Charlise I did them all.
White privilege,
um,
Hashtag not so much.
I hate when white people because they actually had to work for what they wanted
in life.
I think that they're not privileged.
My Dad didn't have a yacht,
therefore,
um,
do you need to look it up?
Does it mean you don't have to work?
It just means at no point was your skin color a,
if anything it was a positive.
Uh,
that's not true.
I was one of the people that put going college.
I like when white people talk about affirmative action to when like nine black
kids get in and they say that's why they weren't able to join the other 30,000
white kids at the university.
Oh that's why that,
that's what it was.
That's what helps you back.
You know,
you couldn't get into the upper fucking 92% of white people who were in the
lower 8% and now I'm supposed to feel bad for you.
Yeah.
Snow flakes.
Snow Flake,
flake,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
so I was doing the dishes and I wore a long sleeve shirt cause it gets a little
cool out here in the desert in the morning.
So I wear a long sleeve workout shirt so I didn't want to get any water.
My sleep's fucking grosses me out the same way.
When I put lotion on,
I take my wedding ring off cause I don't like when it gets underneath the ring
and fucking grosses me out.
So I take off my shirt and I'm standing there shirtless watch and,
um,
relaxed ladies,
upstanding,
the shirtless washing dishes.
Um,
the way I wish my wife would.
and it was reminded me of every joke that I heard a bunch of comics do back in
the day when they were talking about cops go in.
Like,
is there a rule that when you get arrested you have to not be wearing his shirt
then never wearing a shirt?
And it was fucking true.
And it finally dawned on me today,
probably that was because a lot of them couldn't afford air conditioning.
You know,
and God knows,
you know,
they want to get a lot of seasons when they first did cops,
they're like,
well,
how many,
how can you get five seasons out of this?
It's like,
well,
we're mainly gonna shoot in Florida and down south and everybody knows it gets
hot down there harder than Junebug fucking a lampoon are going to cook in July
morning.
Um,
so that's my theory with the no shirt thing.
I also think it's a fuck,
it's something that's done by people that go in and out of jail.
That's just part of the culture is,
you know,
you don't wear a shirt the same way.
Like,
uh,
you know,
the people that go to like the fucking Ivy League schools,
you got to wear like the fucking that do shout fit,
whatever the fuck you call that.
The Khaki pants with the fucking loafers.
This,
that fucking thing that,
you know,
it's actually one of my favorite looks when the white person steers into being
white rather than being ashamed of it.
You know what I mean?
Or are trying to put on a blue collar jacket,
you know,
cause every,
once every two days you go out,
walk down to the fucking mailbox to get you fucking mail.
You know,
I like people that fucking steer into it.
what does that look called?
It's like I can't,
I,
I have like a vague
that,
that thing on Instagram that don't be a bread.
I love the way those kids dress.
You know,
the parents had money and now they know they're getting it and they're not
ashamed of it.
They don't have one ounce of guilt and they're just like,
listen,
my daddy polluted all the rivers and when I take over,
I'm going after the oceans.
You know,
you got to respect it.
It's my goal in that,
uh,
there'll be no more polar bears by the time I'm done running my daddy's company.
I enjoy that.
I liked that.
Just a little bit of honesty.
That's all,
you know,
just being who the fuck you are.
All right.
Um,
I watched the f one yesterday.
Did anybody see the first race of the year down in Australia,
Australia?
Uh,
Grand Prix,
the local favorite.
Daniel Ricardo,
was he from
Perth Resting Place of the great bind?
Scott.
Okay.
And he's with the Renault team this year.
Who,
by the way,
I love the look of their cars,
the yellow and the black.
That looks cool as hell.
Granted,
I'm a Bruins Fan,
so I dunno.
Maybe that's what it is,
but I think those cars are cool as shit.
And this poor bastard Danny Ricardo.
The fucking,
the race,
just start.
He barely goes on the grass in the front end of his car.
Fucking blows up
his front wing,
hit something and the whole front of the car we're going to get fucking
exploded.
So here's my question.
Why do they have bumpy grass like that?
Deb Is,
I hit a tree stump or something,
especially right there near the start.
Somebody always goes off the grass a little bit,
fucked up his car and then he was like a layer to go in and change the nose
after the front.
Uh,
the first lap and then he's down a lap and then his car just shit the bed and
it's just like he left red bull for this.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
I'm,
I'm basically,
I root for Daniel Ricardo
for some reason I root for Ruf Ferrari knowing that they're just not going to
get it done.
I root for the Haas team cause that's the American team.
We did all right yesterday.
Do you think,
you know,
one out of two people finishing as good.
Um,
but you know,
we did come in,
uh,
what's his face?
Magnuson came in sixth place.
Eight big points.
Right.
And what's his face?
Who was the other driver?
We got there with the hell's his name.
Roman Grogan.
Yeah.
He didn't finish.
Um,
well where the fuck were the Ferrari's?
The Ferrari's?
We're in fourth and fifth Max for STAPP and who's basically,
I think going to be the next Lewis Hamilton if he could get a better ride.
Cause for whatever fucking reason,
those red bull cars,
you know,
they,
if they have taken fuck with the Ferrari's,
but now with the Mercedes,
so one and two was Valtteri Botox and Lewis Hamilton.
I'm trying,
you know,
I,
I love greatness,
but I just,
I can't get into the fact how Lewis Hamilton thinks Valtteri botox should
basically be his gimp.
Right.
Both times had this amazing start.
Lord said the Poli fucking blows by him and the first turn and then he just
pulled away for the rest of the goddamn race Lewis who's having his issues.
And whenever that happens,
he always acts like a baby.
You started bitching that Valtteri was too far in front of him,
wasn't helping them out.
It's like,
when the fuck do you want to do that for him?
Ah,
okay.
Just a fucking,
I,
you know what,
he just,
he reminds me of a couple of comedians and actors that I've worked with,
like with a whole fucking seen the whole show.
It's about them
all right.
And if overall what happened was good,
but are part of it wasn't as good as they like the,
they,
they have a little fucking hissy fit.
Maybe that's why he's fucking great because he is great.
And I would never say that he wasn't,
but Jesus,
he always had like,
I've seen like,
you know,
I've seen Vettel not winning last year and Kimmy Reagan and was going to win
something or he was out in front of him.
I heard him fucking bitching about it.
He just rear ends people in front of them.
Uh,
just bug,
you know,
Mercedes is winning.
You're a team.
You took first and second you find,
I know,
I know.
The whole deal is the way he's wired.
That's why he's so great.
But it's just like,
it's such a fucking,
it's such a chick move.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like if you have some shit you have to do that day is a guy,
you go out and do it.
If your wife's got a bunch of shit,
she just be like,
I thought maybe you could come with me.
We could maybe have like a lunch duty drag into it.
MMM.
You wouldn't know it.
But I still love the guy.
You know,
I can never hate on fucking greatness.
The guy is fucking great.
But that part of him,
you know,
I guess we all have that part of ourselves that maybe we could all work on.
Um,
anyways,
I'm very excited that it's,
it's,
it's back.
F one is back.
You know,
it was cool.
They were like,
it's better.
Hundred and 12 days since the last race.
And I was thinking like,
well,
I haven't drank in 113 days.
So freckles.
I took a day off right before the last race of last year.
Um,
I'm almost a third of the way in to breaking my record of 367 days since I
started drinking man.
And went the first 15 years of my life.
Never had a drop.
I don't see myself beating that streak anytime soon.
Um,
so I think I'm going to try to go until June of next year.
Yeah.
So then I would do a calendar year,
January to December,
and then I would also do an entire birthday,
like my entire time of being 51 I didn't have a drop.
I think that would be cool.
Then I would go on for like a fucking year and seven months.
Right.
And at that point I have all the alcohol out of my house.
And then I think what I do is I,
uh,
I don't drink in La.
I don't drink at home.
And when I go on the road,
mmm.
One day out of the,
I go on the road two weekends a month and one day out of those things.
So I'd be drinking two times a month,
24 times a year.
Okay.
Whatever the fuck you gonna do,
I think that'd be all right.
You know,
I got to figure out what the fuck's gonna open for me.
All my open is a fucking the crushing it now Paul Versey check out the tour
dates.
Joe.
Nick,
you gotta check out puck off.
He's got,
uh,
the fuck did he just have on there,
Darren McCarty.
He's still in the pie.
The Fuck Nhl Awards.
Writing on that,
eh?
Just say that.
What the fuck am I going to have now?
You know,
fucking law heads down to San Diego,
crushing it on the sports radio.
See,
this is what happens when you don't bring cupcakes on the road.
They move up into the business.
So I'm just putting it out there.
Are you the funny guy at the office?
Do you think that you'd like to be a standup comedian?
Well,
why don't you submit your tape to build bird.com?
Maybe you could play some chuckle hut.
Do 15 minutes in front of a bunch of animals before you bring up the freckled
brick who's closing out the show.
Oh,
by the way,
how about those Bruin?
So Conor Mcgregor has showed up,
right?
I missed the whole game.
That's why,
of course,
it was fucking exciting.
I missed the whole Goddamn game.
I came in right at the end of the streak.
I watched two games where they continued it and then they lost two in a row and
then I missed the next game and they went in and over time,
Brad Marshawn
fucking and over time.
And then he does the Conor McGregor celebration.
I missed the whole goddamn thing.
But you know what I did see,
I did see,
uh,
that maple leaf's game.
Who the fuck were they playing?
Somebody who had like a big,
big time lead like a five to two lead and they came back and won it.
Oh,
they were in the Saint Patrick State Jerseys.
What has happened to my short term memory?
It's out the window.
Um,
I got to start playing brain games again.
Who the fuck were they playing?
Anyways?
I,
uh,
Toronto was my day.
If the Bruins don't want it this year,
Toronto's my teeth.
That's who the fuck I root for it in the West.
I always root for the Saint Louis Blues.
Those are the two teams that have gone the longest without winning the fucking
thing.
And A,
I don't want,
Oh,
how much longer do you want their,
their fans to suffer?
Which is why I think it's bullshit.
When that was an Antonio Brown,
whatever his fucking name is,
that wide receiver from,
from the Steelers has a fallen out with his team.
The bills make a deal.
They're like,
all right,
you're coming in.
And he's just like,
yeah,
no,
I'm not going there.
You guys suck.
Yeah.
Then he goes to the fucking rate is,
it's just like,
so what a bills fan supposed to do.
I've never understood that.
John Elway,
I'm not playing for the colts.
Well,
they need not play in the NFL.
CFL.
You can't.
Alright,
Colby.
Bryan,
I'm not playing for the Charlotte Hornets swelling,
joy Europe.
It's not how it works.
I want to go where I'm good with kids do when immediately,
um,
bunch of fucking babies.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I guess I understand maybe the quarterback position just because if he don't
have an offensive line that you just got to get right,
but you're playing fucking basketball,
Jesus Christ,
you can't even touch anybody anymore.
Right.
And I can say this,
having not played organized sports for 40 years,
I know what it takes.
Uh,
you know what mean it's,
this is just me bitch.
And as a fan,
I was excited to see the bills get a,
an offensive weapon there,
you know?
Do you want to see a bunch of grown men cry?
You wait to the day,
the fucking bills when,
when the goddamn Superbowl.
All right.
And when the red sox finally won it,
everybody was fucking freaky.
You wait to when the bills went,
let's,
people are going to run outside crying.
The tears are going to freeze on their face because they live in buffalo and
they just going to hug their neighbor,
right?
And then they're going to fall down and land on that little heating thing that
heats up there fucking engine in the morning and it's going to unplug.
And the next morning,
I remember my rabbi,
rabbi,
rabbi [inaudible] rap.
It's not going to fucking start and they're not going to give a shit.
They're going to get mad for half a second.
Then they go,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
They fucking,
they won the Superbowl.
Now I,
I don't,
I don't give a shit anymore.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
plowing ahead here.
What else am I going to do today?
I'm going to go get it.
I'm getting three Mris.
I'm finally going to finally see what's going on with my shoulders and then my
left knee.
That's what I'm doing today.
And we'll fix my,
uh,
both my shoulders and my knee and then,
I'll probably have some sort of cancer from all that radiation.
See,
that's how it works.
Everybody,
you know,
it's one of the reasons why I love breaking bad is every time they've made a
step forward,
they,
there was always a price to pay.
And at best they were even,
but they never really were.
They always sank down a little bit lower.
You know,
it doesn't make any fucking sense.
I'll tell you everybody,
this world,
this world doesn't make any fucking sense to me.
Yeah.
This whole fucking,
yeah.
Food thing in boosting.
Here's something.
I finally had an epiphany
about being in an adult and addiction and being fat and fucking,
all of this shit that you try to avoid is,
um,
no one ever really tells you
like the,
the level of responsibility of when you go out on your own just for yourself
to not fuck the whole thing up.
I was sitting there,
right?
I'm on the Instagram and one of the people I follow,
he's in his twenties,
right?
Eddie's Fellman like the night out.
All right.
His drummer.
Okay.
And everybody's drinking,
everybody's dancing.
Hey,
just keeps going and going and going and going and going until like fucking four
in the morning.
And um,
I understand that you do that when you're at that age,
but there was a part of me thinking like,
what if I didn't do that?
Not like I danced in the street,
but you know what I mean.
I,
I puked in the street til like four in the fucking morning.
What if I didn't do that?
Like,
how many more miles on this engine,
what I have,
you know,
cause like right now,
I'll tell you my drug is eight hours sleep,
honey.
MMM.
I don't know,
just as far as like,
I was really sitting there like,
trying to think how I'm going to explain that to my daughter one day.
It's like,
all right,
you going off to college now you're gonna have this ridiculous level of freedom.
I remember the first time when I finally fucking moved out.
I remember I was in New York City.
It was my first night hanging out.
I was hanging out at the comic strip
and
it hit me.
It's like I don't have to fucking go home until I want to go home.
I don't have to answer to fucking anybody.
This big grin just broke out on my face like,
Jesus Christ,
this is fucking amazing.
Because of course I was down there like Jesus Christ,
they moved like two states away.
I don't fucking know anybody.
I'm in a railroad apartment,
you know,
I just talked to Lucian rest his soul and he's like,
yeah,
guardian of an old white guys.
I have no need.
Rio,
good luck with your dream.
Um,
I remember just sitting there at that bar and then,
but then the epiphany was that Jesus Christ,
I could fucking do whatever I want.
I can fucking meet a chick,
take a home.
It's just fucking unbelievable.
And fortunately during that time,
everybody that I was hanging out with was either they didn't drink or they were
already in Aa.
And I've always just been,
you know,
I just did what people around,
nobody around me,
he's drinking.
They want to go on and go to a diner instead.
I would just fucking do that.
So I didn't drink a lot in my twenties,
but somewhere in my thirties and kind of went off the fucking rails and a,
I wish I could go back at tiff.
I can tell you guys anything yet.
Don't bring the booze into the house.
Have,
it's like literally,
why would you bake cookies and cake and potato chip into your house?
You're going to become a fat fuck.
You bring bows in the house.
She got to become a drunk.
I'm not saying an alkie,
but it'll just be something that you just fucking do it.
If you like smoking a cigar,
don't buy humor door,
keep it at,
don't bring the devil in the house,
keep them down the fucking street.
You get any of that deal is because you'll sit there for 10 minutes being like,
ah fuck man,
I'd love a goddamned cigar or I'd love to go get a drink in there.
But then you sit in there and I got fucking get dressed,
I got to get in the car to you know,
fuck this.
I'll just,
you know,
I'll just sit here and hang out.
But the,
the one thing I have,
this really fascinates me is now that I don't,
um,
I'm really not doing anything is uh,
getting used to just being sober
and I don't just mean,
you know,
booze.
I mean then also combining that with trying to eat right
cause it's like at the end of the night,
like I'm just used to being ramped up,
having a couple of pops and then when you quit boozing then that becomes like
food.
Like,
eat something sugary or eat something salty and you know,
Leno just fucking get the rpms going in your body.
And then when the reality is your body doesn't want to do that,
it just wants to be fucking idling,
chilling out,
saving it's stuff for when you've got to run from an earthquake,
a fire or some guy with an ax essentially.
And uh,
I dunno,
I feel like I need to take,
uh,
you know,
that shit that you put in your gas tank to clean out your engine,
but then you get nervous.
Am I going to move the clots around?
Feel like I got to fucking do that,
man.
Um,
so now my big thing is like,
I've,
I've been cooking at home and last night I asked for the first time in forever.
I made like a full meal,
like two sides in a,
in an eye.
It'll look a little stinks.
I made this little steak,
I had some steamed Broccoli and then,
uh,
I had the potatoes,
right?
Garlic was a little bit of Rosemary,
a little bit of salt and pepper and some butter.
Oh my God,
they were fucking delicious.
That was basically,
that was the highlight of my night was those mashed potatoes.
Um,
but uh,
I'm going to fucking,
I'm trying to revamp my whole lifestyle here.
Um,
so when I returned to drinking,
which I will at some point,
I just want to make sure that I do it in a,
a part like the way I drink soda or pop a few people in the Midwest like
occasion.
Like if I have like a bomb out,
it's usually back east.
If I'm having a pizza,
then I would always get a coke.
And even then I can never really felt,
I could never really finish it.
If I'm just having a bad meal,
I'll have like a coke or something like that.
If I could just do that with booze.
It was fucking people that could just have a glass of wine.
Oh,
that was delicious.
That complemented my meal.
Right.
They don't sit there like a pirate and fucking bite the cork office.
Yeah.
Um,
anyway,
I did a,
uh,
I did a Gig at the American legion.
I got to open for Ron White.
I worked with Joe to,
and um,
this other guy,
Alex,
I didn't get his last name.
He's fucking hilarious.
And a and John's sites.
We had a fucking great time and uh,
afterwards,
you know,
we smoke some cigars and stuff and there was a couple of buddies of mine,
they showed up in,
one of them showed up.
He bought a fucking,
one of those new Indian motorcycles,
the one that looks like the Harley road king.
Ah,
fuck dude.
I would love one of those two tone.
He had black with the green man.
That thing was fucking sick.
And uh,
and all those guys in those big bites,
they always go,
it's like riding a Cadillac.
You know,
it's getting,
it's got the three lights people can see.
Ah,
um,
ah man,
that's,
that's one of those fucking that owner remain the dad fantasy.
It's like if I didn't have a kid,
if I didn't,
if I wasn't living for somebody else,
Thou my God,
I would fucking get one of those.
I would take it out Sunday mornings.
Right.
It's drive down the fucking street.
I freckled arms out,
you know,
feeling like I'm in a motorcycle gang when I really never killed anybody.
Pay My taxes quarterly.
I blocked that part out.
Right.
Drive down the street.
Um,
I would fucking love one of those.
I love those boots as a bikes.
I love,
I love those big ones with the,
uh,
the white wall tires and shit like that.
Like I love a Harley rode king without the bags on it.
I just think that that is just one of the fucking coolest looking bikes ever.
Um,
who knows?
My daughter graduates high school,
goes off to college.
Maybe I'll do it then I'll be like my late sixties.
Yeah,
I'll get one of those.
That's right around the time when you get that three wheeler fucking motorcycle,
you know,
um,
which I would think in a lot of ways could be a little bit more dangerous.
All of a sudden you kind of had to like,
I dunno,
like how does that work?
If somebody cuts out in front of you and you've got to lay it down,
you can't lay it down.
What do you do?
Um,
are you just fucking t bone the guy and go flying over the fucking,
I don't know.
There's gotta be some sort of Robo cop type thing that they can put on.
Can you buy one of those moto GP suits with like the fucking air bag in it and
shit.
They don't have an air bag for your head.
That's the problem.
Wait a second.
Moto g p riding suit for sale.
The single be like five grand.
If they do
well there's one for $478.
So you know that's not it.
I should've put air bag in there
with airbag and then you going to like that would,
the thing is like,
that's like hooked onto the bike.
Yeah.
Come on.
You fucking cunts.
Shop race shop race suits with airbags.
All right.
Amazon
is one for 1000 bucks.
There's one for fourth,
1500 bucks.
All right.
This sounds about right.
You know the Moto GP,
once we actually got one of those,
it's like fucking three grand.
But it's a thing.
You can have one of those and it's not going to help you.
If someone in an SUV runs you over.
And another life,
I would have had kids younger and then I would have lived in the middle of
nowhere and I would've had one.
Oh,
well.
Um,
speaking of motorcycles,
motorcycle,
uh,
Japanese and Italian motorcycles,
I don't have any advertising this week.
All right.
Japanese and Italian motorcycles.
Hey,
bill,
on your mom match 14th podcasts.
You wondered why Japanese and Italian companies make better motorcycles.
That's not what,
all right.
Had a little glitch there and ran out of batteries,
ran out of batteries.
Um,
getting back to what I was saying,
I didn't say that you guys make better motorcycles.
You just make the fast ones.
Like,
why don't mean when I was in Honda Indian or somebody like that and make a fast
one?
Um,
one explanation I've heard they're probably better,
but as an American,
I can't fucking say that.
One explanation I heard is that after World War II engineers and designers for
the access military industry industrial complex,
we're forced to find civilian and nonmilitary work.
Some of the brightest,
smartest engineers in those countries ended up in automotive,
motorcycles and electronics,
Honda,
Yamaha,
Sony,
Ferrari,
Lamborghini,
Ducati,
or too catty,
as they say in England in particular,
or at least the announcer does in particular,
aeronautical engineers who had designed a fighter planes,
found success applying their knowledge to motorcycle chassies designed because
many of the forces acting on a plane's fuselage is similar to the forces on a
motorcycle leaned over,
going through a turn.
That's fascinating.
Also because of rationing in the years following World War II engineers and
former access countries had to figure out how to design and manufacturer with
less raw material like steel or aluminum.
You can see how efficient the engineered German Italian and Japanese engines are
compared to a chunky Harley Davidson motorcycle.
Uh,
just post ride Chet,
I've heard over the years,
but I thought you might find it interesting.
Thanks for making me laugh and making your podcast.
That is really interesting.
Something else.
Um,
is that just the sheer amount of space that we have over here,
you know,
that if we're not driving down these little streets that used to ride a fucking
horse and buggy around in that everything needs to be really,
the cars,
motorcycles gotta be quick and nimble and all of that.
You could just fucking,
you know,
if you look at our cars,
it's the same thing.
It's all about zero 60 in a straight line because for the most part there's not
a lot of turns and shit,
you know,
that we're going to be taking.
So I think part of it is also that,
but I really find that interesting that,
um,
just through,
you know,
a loss comes a win like that,
that's usually what happens.
That reminds me,
I was watching,
um,
uh,
that Joe Rogan podcast with Mike Tyson and he was alluding to the fact and a lot
of boxes have that.
Like,
you know,
boxing is basically that.
There's never been like a rich kid that I can think of that just,
you know,
came from a great background.
Everything just goes in and does that.
Like it's for somebody that just came from nothing and you can literally,
literally fighting your way out of it.
Um,
that would be fucking hilarious though if one of those don't be a Brad kids
actually came,
you know,
you know one of those kids that accidentally kills his girlfriend while having
rough sex.
Remember those fucking billionaire boy club fucking lunatics from the 80s.
Uh,
if one of him,
he came in and if he just steered into it like a great wrestling heel,
like when he did his interviews,
he had his boat shoes with no socks on and khaki pants
and he's just in his old thing is even though we came up with all that money and
shit,
he's just like a complete fucking sociopath.
Uh,
and then goes in and like,
his nickname should just be staring into all of that shit.
Like what the fuck would it be?
It'd be like,
uh,
Brad,
the trust fund kid,
you know,
fucking
van something or other as always the fucking rich white people names.
Right.
I missed that.
I missed the Robert Barron being famous,
you know?
Right.
I missed it the first time,
but like
JP Morgan,
ah,
Andrew Carnegie I have and nobody else,
then it just all became a corporation.
I think that that's why they did it.
They became a corporation.
So then they,
their names wouldn't be out there.
So now it's like,
can you believe what Alberta that raw diggy believe.
What would a Monsanto,
you don't have one fucking name,
you know,
just as far as barroom chatter goes.
Sure.
If he actually took the time to care enough to research agenda,
you'd know a name.
All right.
I think I was kind of shitting on myself by the end there.
Um,
all right,
what else do we got here?
Marginal tax rate.
Hey Bill,
I'm listening to a recent podcast where you talk about [inaudible] plan to tax
people at a higher rate.
Uh,
the marginal tax rate kicks in after someone earns their first $10 million.
After that,
the income is taxed at 70%.
Do Fuck that.
Fuck that.
That doesn't touch people who create startups yet does,
when they turn around,
sell it for fucking
tens of millions of dollars.
Of course it does.
Yeah.
Most comedians don't make anything close to that.
You don't even know what comedians make.
That's not fucking true.
Comedians are crushing it right now.
And secondly,
what I fucking hate about all of this shit is everybody's going to ignore the
reason why we're broke.
We're broke because we're fighting this never ending fucking war that is lining
the pockets of about fucking a half a dozen to a dozen corporations and it's
completely bankrupted this fucking country.
So rather than take those people to task,
who pay all the fucking politicians,
now you're going to go after regular fucking citizens and we're going to have to
pay the tab.
Go Fuck Yourself,
dude.
70% tax on anything is fucking criminal.
Criminal
to take more than half somebody is doing that work.
You don't get more than half of that go fuck itself.
Those politicians need to grow a fucking Dick and some fucking balls and stand
up to those corporations that they're fucking blowing.
That's the solution.
Fucking God damn fucking people who sit there and they demonize anybody.
Any individual that went out and went after a dream and made it,
and then they have to turn around and subsidize your fucking life.
Go Fuck Yourself.
You really want to take down the rich.
Go after these fucking corporations that have all their money in offshore
fucking accounts.
Kick them out of the fucking country and stop buying this shit.
Don't fucking punish some person because they started dollar shave club and
they're fucking dormitory.
Now all of a sudden they got to give 70% of it away.
You know what you sound like?
You sound like somebody who's never going to make $10 million in their life.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That drives me up the fucking wall,
and that's the genius.
Once again of corporations.
It's,
there's no name,
there's no face to it,
but she can do it with individuals,
so now they're going to get punished.
Anyways,
let me finish this.
After the income,
it's taxed 70% that doesn't talk to people could create startups.
That's just a statement that you pulled out of your ass.
Most comedians don't make anything close to that that's pulled out of your ass.
That's pulled out of your Reps.
I've seen like the top fucking,
um,
earning comedians that Forbes fucking lists are all over 10 million.
Some of them are making $20 million.
They're supposed to give 70% of over 10 million away
anyways.
Uh,
the most skilled brain surgeons don't make that much.
The people making more than 10 million a year,
our close with extremely high concentrations of wealth.
No,
they're not.
This is this what this is what you're doing,
dude.
What you're doing is you're creating this cartoon character of a rich person.
The same way female comics created a cartoon character of a white male comedian
where he just goes down to the club and the club owner goes,
what are your dreams?
How many doors can I open for you?
Nobody wants to see that it's fucking work.
I can't even,
I can't even read the fucking rest of this.
That's like that person going,
someone who makes $10 million a year.
It doesn't work any harder than someone who makes $20,000 a year.
It's like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
If you work for yourself,
I don't care what the fuck you make a year.
It never ends.
It's,
it's seven days a week,
three 65 you're working your fucking ass off
anyways.
Collecting it at a rate that is unnecessary for unhuman any human on earth.
Being able to start from nothing is what makes America great.
Yeah,
you're gonna Yank all these people back down again.
Those people also will make that they create a bunch of fucking jobs.
There's a way to run your country that your company,
right.
Anyways,
listen,
is being able to start from nothing is what makes America great and if anything,
a higher tax rate enables more Americans to follow their dreams.
That is complete bullshit because what you're going to do is just yank your
fellow fucking country men down to the ground.
None of this shit.
You're not going to get to go out to these fucking corporations there and all
these super rich people,
their money's already out of the country.
They got it running through fucking 20 different islands and that's 20 different
fucking mountains are red tape that the IRS is not going to take their time to
go through and that's why they're going to go after just regular fucking people
because we're standing here with their fucking pants down,
allowing people to hoard massive amounts of wealth only shrinks the middleclass
creating larger conglomerates and pushes us further towards a horrible dystopia
where everything is commercialized.
Well,
first of all,
dude,
you're about 40 fucking years too late at that party,
all right?
It all,
you're all,
you're all these fucking tax things are going to do.
They're not going to fuck with any corporation.
They fucking brush the IRS off their shoulder like it's a fucking net.
All you're going to do is you're going to go after new money.
Somebody went out and started something.
Who the fuck are you to say how much money anybody can fucking make because you
don't have an idea that will enable you to make $10 million.
Somebody has to fucking subsidize your life and you're going to ignore the
fucking elephant in the room and you just going to go after the fucking
individual.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I didn't want to fucking hear this.
This is this fucking bullshit that that fucking chick is talking about there,
that everybody's all high and mighty on.
She's talking about individuals.
She's not going to go out after the co corporations
that she's going to go out and give speeches to after she's done with her
political career to the two and a 300 fucking grand a night,
just like the fucking Obama's,
but everybody's going to sit there and act like it's only the bushes in the
trumps.
The fucking fucking,
Obama's just like the Clintons are lining their pockets with that same fucking
corporate money that is never going to be fucked with and they just,
they're going to go,
I have to stand up comics people that start apps,
people who start dollar shave club,
that who the,
who the fuck is going to get yanked down.
And you sat there and whenever we've all set back,
support the troops,
see he can't fucking speak out against the war.
And you literally watched them bankrupt this fucking country.
And every year in August,
we're like,
we don't have any more money.
We don't have any money.
What's the solution?
Do we go after the fucking banks?
Do we go after the corporations?
No,
we just raised the level of debt that this country is going to accept and now
we're going to turn around and we're going to make sure that no individual who
doesn't fucking pour water in the fucking,
uh,
rivers and put water poor fucking,
that there are chemicals in the Goddamn rivers and all that.
Shit's just,
just let all of those fucking people,
all of those cons who fucking polluted your fucking God damn food supply to the
point you got girls getting their fucking periods at nine years old and a kid
can grow a fucking full beard by the time he's 10 ignore all of that shit.
Yeah,
and just sit there and be like,
I don't think you need to make 10 million.
Let's go fuck yourself.
You know what buddy?
I hope you make $10 million and I hope you get to keep more than God damn
fucking 30% of it because you earned it.
You should have to pay cause you fucking cause a what could you earn too much
fucking money.
Listen,
I've got to tell you something right now.
If these corporations were paying their fair fucking share,
I wouldn't have a problem with this and you.
If you wanted to cap it at $10 million,
fine,
but that's not what the fuck you going to do.
All right,
I've got heated there.
Yeah.
Fucking God damn stupid ass fucking morons out there with you.
Why don't you read up on what the fuck it takes?
Why don't you read up on what it takes to fucking go from not having anything to
fucking get in there?
Why don't you actually figure out how hard you have to fucking work to even get
anywhere close to half of that fucking money.
Yeah.
How fucking strong you have to be mentally.
How much bullshit you have to get put through as you fucking watching other
people around you that you started out with,
watching them slowly go crazy,
watching them kill themselves and all of this other fucking shit,
and then turn a complete blind eye to fucking banks and corporations and all of
these fucking assholes.
Let,
yeah,
let's go off to people making months.
Yeah.
Fucking nationwide drug epidemic.
Let's just completely ignore all the fucking pharmaceutical companies.
That's fine.
Let's just go after Joe blow.
Who fucking worked his fucking balls off?
You know
who the fuck are you to say what the fuck?
Just a certain segment of people are going to fucking make and you're going to
ignore all those goddamn corporations and don't even fucking tell me that.
Oh,
go after them to how they run the fuck they run.
All of these fucking politicians,
every one of them's on their fucking knees blown them.
And occasionally when you got a like Bernie Sanders who actually wants to stand
up to those costs,
what do they do?
They fucking box him out and give them no coverage whatsoever.
And then one of the way do they go with the fucking made man,
the Hillary Clinton,
right?
And then she loses to this orange headed can and now we're dealing with this
shit.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right.
Mother-In-Law was some messed up passive aggressive behavior.
All right,
I have to end this podcast soon cause I gotta go fucking,
Oh my God.
Nobody who's making,
who's not making $10 million should fucking be telling somebody what they should
be.
Fine.
Am I saying what the fuck you should be paying?
I want to hear what your fucking ideas that I'm going to bet that if I ever get
over 10 million,
I'm going to be fucking subsidizing
what's,
you can sit on your fucking ass and not do anything.
And if a fucking nine to five job and it'll be over right at fucking five
o'clock on Friday and you could do whatever the fuck you want for the rest of
your fucking weekend.
Well,
poor people who fucking are running companies got to figure out through the
weekend how to keep that thing afloat so you still have your fucking job.
Then on top of that,
they're supposed to give 70% of their money over 10 million a year.
She can get another fucking beanbag chair.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Unbelievable.
We haven't,
we still haven't.
We shown that just giving people fucking money doesn't do anything.
There really is that fantasy that,
you know,
if you give people fucking opportunity,
uh,
you know they're going to make something of themselves not true.
That's only half the recipe.
That's like,
if you get a bag of sugar,
you can make a pie.
No,
you can't.
You need fucking eggs,
Ede,
you all kinds of other fucking shit.
Somebody has to have the drive,
they have the vision and they gotta be strong enough.
Then when they keep getting a dick knock in the dirt to keep fucking getting up
and stay in positive and not letting his fucking business eat you up.
I had a fucking texted my buddy of mine last night.
I couldn't believe I haven't talked to him.
Well how fucking negative you got and I'm trying to find a nice way to say,
dude,
don't let this business get to you.
Don't let them put the fucking pilot laid out.
Cause when they do,
you're fucking done.
All right.
I never had to have that fucking talk when I was unloading trucks working in a
warehouse.
I don't know.
Listen,
I am all for fucking pay in taxes and all of that shit.
If they would actually spend it on fucking the public schools,
if they would,
if they would actually
spending on trying to give people tax breaks to fucking keep industry in this
goddamn country and they haven't everybody who's thought about themselves and
they'd sent the thing out the fucking window.
So now what's going to happen is you're going to start going after the
individual and somehow demonize somebody that actually went after dreaming is
corrupted.
His function country is actually got,
you're not going to fucking yank his fucking pants down the fuck outta here.
Fucking bullshit.
I think for you to make a statement like that,
at some point in your life,
you should.
You should actually have made over $10 million a fucking year.
So maybe you'd have a little bit of empathy.
You could actually speak with some sort of fucking knowledge instead of sitting
there playing the goddamn victim.
All right?
If you want to start a fucking revolution and go off to banks and corporations,
I'm fucking all Ford.
If you want to start yanking other fucking you,
your own fellow country men who've done nothing wrong down by their fucking
ankles because they had the balls to go after something
and fucking actually become successful,
and then you're,
you're going to decide how successful they need to be
because these people are fucking honest enough to actually report their goddamn
income.
They,
meanwhile,
you've got the fucking cartoons,
the Goddamn Corporation after it's gone through 20 fucking Goddamn islands is
now getting a loan from the last fucking island,
uh,
interest free tax free fucking loan.
His money comes back to him in the form of a fucking loan.
And then that Phantom fucking corporation forgives the loan and the guy's paying
0% taxes.
How about that buddy?
How bout that?
Yeah,
but let's ignore corporations that keep us in wars that believed this country,
die dry,
and let's go after the dollar shave club guy.
There you go.
Let's go after the guys who started barstool sports,
yet they're the,
they're the fucking problem motivated fucking people who started from nothing
and,
and hit the mother load.
I don't know.
Jesus Christ.
That was fucking 10 minutes of my life.
I'll never get back.
Alright?
Mother-In-Law was some messed up,
passive aggressive behavior.
Dear Bill,
my boyfriend's mother is probably the most passive aggressive piece of shit you
ever met in your life.
By the way,
I still have to talk about this.
The fucking level of money that I'm making.
I'm lucky if I get to keep a third of it
in on paper.
I'm not paying 70% tag.
You wait until that fucking thing kicks in and if you think they're going to
stop at 10 million and then it's going to be well at 5 million,
shouldn't they pay this at 1 million?
Shouldn't they pay this?
Any check that I get,
any fucking check that I get.
I just,
I take 70% already and throw it out the fucking window with commissions,
expenses and then the taxes that I pay.
That's why people fucking go broke.
They go out and they get $1 million and they think they have $1 million.
It's like you don't,
you have about 375 grand if you're lucky.
That's what $1 million is before you're going to implement this bullshit.
Kind of a fucking American fucking
it is for pulling down another regular guy.
Who was you?
Yeah.
Why not get inspired by that person?
No.
You should give him your money that you made back to me.
You fucking go fuck yourself.
Oh my God.
What?
Doesn't everybody get to play it down?
A Bennett fell football just because their NFL dream didn't make it right.
Why don't you just let him do that?
Uh,
dear bill,
my boyfriend's mother is probably the most passive aggressive piece of shit you
ever met in your life.
She still relatively young in her early fifties and acts like a college kid
around her friends.
Oh boy.
It's probably more annoying than the last 12 minutes of this podcast.
Uh,
you just know that she was a sorority bullied when she was younger and now she
treats her family very passive aggressively.
Oh Wow.
For example,
when she came over for dinner to our house recently,
we asked if she could remove her shoes as we don't appreciate the filth from the
street infecting our floors.
This slighted her from the get go and then she went to the bathroom and
deliberately left skid marks on the toilet
and came out on that announcing to the room that we should clean it regularly to
prevent that from happening.
Oh my God.
I know that sounds crazy,
but this is the same person who also made a big deal about how somebody should
get tested for an STD because my,
oh,
saying how I should get tested for an STD because
my last boyfriend had an uncircumcised penis.
Please let me know what you would do to put her in her place once and for all.
MMM.
Oh,
this is a tough one.
This is family,
a family,
the family bank.
He's um,
mother-in-law with messed up passive aggressive behavior,
but you're calling it your boyfriend.
Yeah.
You got to nip this in the bud before you even fuck or the bud,
whatever the fuck you say.
Nip in the bud before,
uh,
before this goes any fucking further.
MMM.
You don't want to marry into that.
And if you do marry into it,
you got to set up boundaries.
MMM.
Uh,
his deal.
I would just,
uh,
I would say something to your boyfriend
and what I would do,
uh,
that's probably not going to work.
You know what I would do?
I would just say I don't appreciate that comment.
And if you have to have a fight with her and have a fight with her and just say,
listen,
you're coming over my house and they,
these are my rules.
If you don't like it,
don't come over here.
And if she has a fucking problem with that and your boyfriend is a problem with
that,
fuck the both of them.
Fuck the both of them.
All right.
Yeah.
There's no reason for you to be walking around on egg shells where you live,
fuck this fucking person.
And you'll basically show your future mother in law who you and your boyfriend,
who you are and you know,
whoever has a problem with it can go fuck themselves.
You can come over and leave skid marks in my toilet and say somebody should
clean that.
You should should've grabbed her by the back of her fucking neck and the seat of
her pants and thrown her out.
Bounce of style.
Yeah.
Right out of your fucking house.
The fuck out of my house.
Clean up my shit.
Get the fuck out of my house.
That's an easy one.
That's as easy as the $10 million a year.
Um,
thing there.
Uh,
I,
I'm open to it too.
It's hilarious of sale.
I'm open to more debate on that Saturday.
I'll talk to somebody who will actually talk about the corporations and banks.
If you want to talk about that first and what you plan to do with them,
then I will listen to your fucking over $10 million.
And I don't make anywhere near that.
But like I plan to,
I'm building a company,
I plan on that and I don't plan on fucking working my ass off.
So then I could just go give it to a bunch of corrupt cops who aren't going to
give it to you.
They're not gonna give it to you.
They're going to give it in the form of contracts to Pete,
to people at big construction companies to build more luxury,
high rise apartments.
They're going to give them the kickback fucking money and they're going to
charge way more money for the fucking materials.
All of that fucking shit.
Government fucking jobs,
building roads and all of that.
That's where it's gonna go.
It's not going to go back to the kids.
It's not going to go back to the schools and it's not going to go to you.
It isn't.
Yeah,
it never does because they're all fucking corrupt.
So if you want to talk about how to somehow pay politicians more money so they
don't,
so they have fuck you money.
So data,
they don't have to fucking sit there and suck the dicks of these corporations
and these bags.
Then maybe we could try to fucking,
yeah,
have as honest accompanies you see a countries you could possibly have,
which is impossible because people shit on socialism.
They shit on communism.
They shit on capitalism.
None of them work.
None of them work because human beings are inherently flood.
Alright,
so there you go.
That's my uninformed bullshit for the fucking day.
God bless all you.
I got some shit to do.
I know the podcast.
It was a little bit short,
but you're probably sick of me after I was on my tree stump there for fucking 12
minutes.
All right.
God bless all of you.
I hope you dreams come true,
and I hope when you go out and you make the money that you earned,
some cut doesn't come in and take 70% of it.
All right?
See you Thursday.